>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> So our next author's
name is Emma Donoghue.
So Emma Donoghue is not only
an author, she's a playwright,
a literary historian,
novelist, and screenwriter.
Ms. Donoghue wrote the
novel "Room," which was made
into a feature-length film in 2015.
For those of you who haven't read or
seen it, "Room" is a harrowing tale
about a little boy named Jack and
his mother who are held captive
in a shed by Jack's father.
It's a really haunting
story, for sure,
but it's an incredibly moving
depiction of the relationship
between a mother and her child.
The movie "Room" also has
a 94% on Rotten Tomatoes
and it is Certified Fresh, if
that provides further incentive
to see the movie and read the novel.
Ms. Donoghue's most recent novel
"The Lotterys Plus One" came
out this year, in March.
The novel's protagonist is Sumac
Lottery, a 9-year-old girl living
with her big, big family
in a Victorian style house.
In the house are four parents,
six children, and five pets.
How many people have that
many people in their family?
How many people have that many pets?
That's a lot of pets.
Just when we think that Sumac's
family can't get any bigger,
her grandfather moves in
with them and Sumac has
to share a room with
her grandfather.
This novel sounds truly,
truly delightful.
Without further ado, here to discuss
her works with you, Emma Donoghue.
[ Applause ]
Thank you so much.
I think this is the clicker here.
Thank you.
>> Emma Donoghue: Hello all.
It's lovely to be at the
National Book Festival.
It's my first time.
I'm very excited.
I'm particularly excited
that it features sagbags.
I think they should become a
feature at all book festivals,
first time for me and
I'm seeing the appeal.
And I like the way each reader
gets to occupy several sagbags
if they spread out correctly.
I'm going to see if
my clicker works.
I've never had a clicker before.
It's all very exciting.
Yes! And I start with
the elegant hand picture
because when I was a kid
and I wanted to be a writer,
I assumed that it would involve
a lot of exquisite penmanship,
you know, that I'd have a very
elegant hand and maybe a quill pen.
And I was a bit worried that my
handwriting is particularly messy.
So I've been comforted to discover
that the writing life
has not actually had
to include much handwriting.
When I sign people's books and it's
messy, they don't seem to mind.
My writing life in
fact looks like this.
It's messy, not just in
handwriting, but in the mess
that spreads all around me.
So that was one great discovery
for me about the writing life
that you don't have to tidy up.
You don't even have to get dressed.
So this one of my desks here.
It's a pull-out desk on which
I just allow the mess to spill.
And then another of my desks is any
surface I can sit on in my pajamas.
I was waiting, for instance, in the
lunchroom for the authors upstairs.
And I was writing in my
hotel room this morning.
So my advice to young readers
to would be to write anywhere
and don't let any day get away
from you just because you happen
to be sitting on a bus, say.
My third desk is my treadmill desk,
which I thought I'd
show you a picture
of because people often don't
quite understand how a treadmill
desk works.
This is the lazy author's
best friend because a couple
of years ago there was a lot
of publicity about how sitting
down all the time was very
bad for you and was likely
to shorten your life and I realized
that I was spending my entire
day sitting down and had been
since the age of about 4.
So I decided to buy this
treadmill desk and I bought it
without trying it out because I
thought I would probably hate it.
So I hoped by spending the money on
this very expensive treadmill desk
that I would force myself to use.
But actually I love it.
So stand there with my laptop
on the desk bit and I walk along
at several miles an hour,
you know, just thinking,
hands by my side sometimes
and sometimes typing a few
words and it's just great.
It just lets me get my
exercise while I'm writing.
So this book I brought today "The
Lotterys Plus One" is the first one
that I've written mostly
on this treadmill desk.
And that's an illustration someone
did of me on the treadmill desk.
And what I love about illustration
is it gives the impression
that the pages are actually
produced by the desk,
that the desk does my thinking
for me, that it's some kind
of miraculous dream machine and
they have not yet invented that,
but if there's any clever
developer in the audience,
please do because that
would be wonderful
if the treadmill actually
produced more than, you know,
movement and static electricity.
For the first year I spent
on the treadmill desk,
I was getting slight
electric shocks all the time.
That kind of added to the,
you know, keep me on my toes,
keep me awake feeling of it.
I just thought that was what's
it's like to be on a treadmill desk
until I mentioned it on Facebook
and somebody told me there's
a thing you can get for $2
which stops the electric shocks.
Excuse me for the transitions.
My 10-year-old helped me put this
PowerPoint presentation together
and she's got quite flashy
taste in transitions.
When I had kids about, let's see, 13
years ago, 13 and then 10 years ago,
lots of other writers came up
to me and said things like,
"Every baby cost you a book!"
What they meant was, you know,
when you have a baby it's going
to take a lot of time out of
your life and you'll be too busy
and you probably won't manage to
write a book in those few years.
But I have found it
to be the opposite,
that having kids was the most
inspiring thing I've ever done.
So that's what my children, Finn and
Una, in a pair of cardboard boxes.
I didn't keep them stored
that way all the time.
Okay, it was voluntary.
They like to play in boxes
and with boxes and they
like to box each other up.
So when they were this age, I heard
about a case of a child being born
into kidnapping situation
and I thought, wow,
a child who was growing
up in a locked room,
I guess he would just play with
whatever things there were,
you know, and then I looked
at my son and I thought,
he'd be okay in a situation
like that.
He'd play with everything.
He'd have little dancers
between the spoon and the fork.
So that really was what inspired
me to write my novel "Room"
in which a child who's 5 not only
is growing up in a locked room
but thinks that that
is the whole world.
And it was slightly inspired
by something my mother used say
and my mother had eight of us.
So that was our normal,
an Irish Catholic family.
She had eight children.
And my mother used to say
that whenever she went
into a public toilet, you know, went
in the cubicle and shut the door,
she'd see our little hands coming
under the door, wanting her
and she would get the impulse
to kind of stomp on the hands
to make us go away
but she never did.
She never did but she
had that feeling of oh,
please leave me alone,
just for one minute!
And so I thought that the mother
in my book might sometimes
find it very difficult to be
with her kids all the time but that
the boy in the story would love it.
This is my favorite piece of fan
art and a fan sent this to me
to describe what it was like
for her to read my novel "Room."
You see her face in the book.
She felt entirely locked into
the room and scared and anxious.
And although it's a scary
image, I love the idea
that my readers would feel
as if they are actually
living inside one of my books.
That's a real thrill to me.
So my kids grew up.
As you can see, they're a bundle
of long limbs in the photo.
And as they got older and I was
reading a lot of books with them
and getting so caught up
in the books with them,
I began think I'd love to
write a book about not only
about kids but a book for kids.
So I conceived the idea of
"The Lotterys Plus One."
I'm showing you the French cover
there because I just think it looks
so sophisticated once it's in
French, you know, [foreign words].
And I'm going to read you
just the very first page
from "The Lotterys Plus One."
In fact, it's a series and
this page is going to be
at the start of all the books.
One upon a time a man from Delhi
and man from Yukon fell in love,
and so did a woman from
Jamaica and a Mohawk woman.
The two couples became best
friends and had a baby together.
When they won the lottery,
they gave up their jobs
and they found a big old house
where the family could learn
and grow and grow some more.
Now Sumac Lottery, age 9,
is the fifth of seven kids,
all named after trees.
With their four parents and
five pets, they fit perfectly
in the Toronto home
they call Camelottery.
But the one thing in life
that never changes is
that sooner or later things change.
So this is a sketch of what
the book would've looked
like if I had done the drawings.
I'm just trying to make you
realize how grateful I am
that I didn't do the drawings.
So luckily, the actual
drawings for the book are done
by the wonderful Caroline
Hadilaksono
and here's a two-page picture
of the entire Lotterys clan.
So as I was saying, a big
family was normal to me.
Eight kids just seemed like how
life was and then when I came
to North America for the first
time, people were just mystified
by how big a family I had been
in but it just felt normal to us,
you know, that you'd all be summoned
to dinner by a cowbell or a gong
or a drum or something
and that, you know,
there would be a little notebook
with all your bedtimes written in
and all your pocket money
written in and it was a bit
like the Army and a
bit like a family.
So the Lotterys are not
very like the Donoghues
because they're a much
more unconventional family.
In my family, we sort of had to
be home for dinner at 6 o'clock,
for instance, but I did try
to capture that sense of fun
and busyness and a big house, just
full of people and their stories
and their arguments and their
conversations and their jokes.
So the Lotterys began with
the notion of a family
that would have two mothers
because my kids have two mothers,
so I just thought, you
know, why not try that.
But then that on its own didn't
seem interesting enough to me
and I thought what
else could they have.
So I decided to give
them two dads as well.
And then I thought, well, let's make
sure there are quite a lot of kids,
you know, let's just
go big or go home.
So the Lotterys expanded and
then the pets came along.
So all in all it sort of
branched off in all directions.
And I decided to write about a
family so expansive and so welcoming
that they could take a lot of
different things in their stride.
So there's the lovely Caroline
Hadilaksono who did all the pictures
and what I like is how she makes
each character look very different,
because in a way if the
Lotterys have a kind of principle
as a family it's allowing people
to be different from each other,
allowing people to be not the same.
So here's one of the
pictures from the book.
You will see that a scene set at an
airport and there is Lake Ontario
in the background and
that the famous Tower
in Toronto, the CN Tower.
And one reason I have an airport
scene in that book is that I wanted
to make it a book all
about immigrants.
The four parents are all from
different parts of the world.
Only two of them were
born in Canada.
One of them is First Nations.
One of them has Scottish ancestry.
And the other dad is from India
and the other mom is from Jamaica.
So Canada, like The States, is
a country rich in immigrants.
And people have brought so much
different interesting food and music
and dance and language from their
different nations and especially
in an era where people often say
mean things about immigrants.
I wanted this book to be really
celebratory of immigrants.
I'm an immigrant twice
myself being Irish.
I moved to England and
then I moved to Canada.
So in this picture you see
Sumac in the foreground looking
around for her grandfather
who is hiding behind
that pillar there, at the back.
So Sumac is a middle child
and they often neglected,
but she's my point
of view character.
So she really takes
center stage in this book.
And in this particular
picture you see her horrified
to have been banished to the attic
because she had a lovely bedroom
of her own in the family's big
house but she's had to give it
up because her grandfather,
who she's never met before,
has had to suddenly move in
because he's developed dementia.
So he's not thinking
too clearly anymore
and he needs some looking after.
And she's never even
met this man before.
So she's appalled to find,
thank you, that suddenly has
to give up her bedroom to him.
Her favorite sibling is probably
her big brother Sycamore.
I named all the children after trees
but they soon started rebelling
and changing their names a bit.
You know, fictional characters
don't do what they're told.
So he shortened his name
from Sycamore to Sic.
Sic is a very handy little word
that editors used to mean, no,
leave it the way I put it.
Don't change it.
So he calls himself Sic and
he makes his own T-shirts.
So I've had a lot of fun
coming up with a list
of T-shirt slogans he would wear.
And this one, his T-shirt
says, "back to front"
on his front to confuse people.
And he's sitting on his little
sister there to kind of squish some
of the sadness out of her.
The eldest daughter is called
Catalpa and I asked Caroline
to show her, you know, not
smiling in most of the photograph
because she's in that phase of life
where she's wearing a
lot of black, at 14.
One thing I like about these
pictures is that she manages to show
so many different things going on at
the same time, like in the picture
on the right you've got a
light saber battle going
on in the background
as well as fireflies.
The middle brother
was named Redwood,
but he shortened his name Wood and
he's very, very outdoorsy and tries
to spend as much as possible of his
time in the woods behind his house.
And he's got quite excited here
that his grandfather had brought
to the house lots of, you know,
taxidermied heads of hunted animals
in boxes, which appalls Sumac.
One of the types of fun I was
trying to have with this book was
to give the family their own
kind of culture where lots
of things are they
take them for granted
like they're very eco friendly.
They're always recycling.
They go out on garbage night
and they salvage things
and make art out of them.
And many of the things that
seem normal to them like lots
of vegetarian food or, you
know, interesting grains,
their grandfather when he moves
in finds all these
things totally abnormal.
So there's a lot of culture clash.
One of the biggest painful
arguments the family has now is
that the Lotterys like to save
water by not flushing the toilet
until they really need to.
They've got a philosophy which is,
"If it's yellow, let it mellow."
And the grandfather thinks
this is absolutely disgusting
and he keeps going around
flushing anytime he passes.
Aspen is one of my
most useful characters
because he's a troublemaker.
An Aspen tree is always
slightly trembling
and Aspen is in perpetual movement.
This family don't go to school.
They all stay at home and home
school or rather they roam around
and go on a lot of day
trips and home school.
And Aspen likes to get
into a lot of trouble
by claiming things are experiments.
You know, she'll set up
some complicated combination
around the house which is
likely to break a window,
but she'll say she was
doing it as an experiment.
So she's the middle girl and she's
a great maker of stories for me.
Some of the Lotterys got
born into this family
and some of them got adopted.
And one of the things
I decided to do
from the start was not
make a big deal about this.
I couldn't care less which
of them were adopted.
And I didn't ever want that to
be the big heavy issue dealt
with in the book.
So Sumac is adopted and so are
the two youngest children, Brian.
Another interesting
thing about Brian is
that she says she's not a girl.
She's not decided what she is but
she says don't call me a girl.
So she's going by Brian
at the moment
and Brian's gender fluidity is one
of the things I've had
most fun with in this book.
And this particular book, far from
wearing either skirts or trousers,
she wears a cardboard
firetruck for this entire book
until in a tragic scene
it gets left behind
at a outdoor showing
of "The Wizard of Oz."
And the baby of the family, Oak
[inaudible] and he is delayed
because before he came to the
Lotterys somebody shook him.
So Oak needs a lot of looking after
and one of the things I'm dealing
with in the book is how different
family members have different needs.
And sumac is really resentful of
her grandfather needing looking
after because she doesn't know
him and she's not fond of him yet.
But of course she's totally happy
looking after her baby brother Oak.
So I'm looking at lot at how
if a family really works,
then it can be a kind of safety
net for all the different ways
in which different members
needs looking after.
Here's one of the dads, PapaDum,
who's birth name is [inaudible]
and he's the main cook.
Here's the second dad PopCorn.
Quite early on I realized that
some readers would be annoyed
by all these silly nicknames but I
thought, fine, I'll just way bye-bye
to those readers and carry on
with silly names because that kind
of thing, you know, if you're going
to do silly names at all you might
as well have a lot of
silly names and slang.
So in this particular picture
is one of my favorites,
PopCorn has got his glasses
entangled in a mobile
of the solar system, in a
very expensive toy shop.
Here's one of the moms.
She's Mohawk and her name is
CardaMom, which is a spice.
And here's the fourth parent,
MaxiMum who is a [inaudible]
Buddist, so she's always going off
and meditating and the kids or
the cats come and bother her.
In the other picture, you
see her wearing a mask
because she's cleaning up
raccoon poo from their garden.
And the kind of antagonist
or enemy figure
in this book is the grandfather who
the children quickly name Grumps.
And when I was writing this book it
was my first time writing for kids.
And I wondered, you know,
what is still taboo or still
against the rules in
writing for children.
I found that most things are not
really against the rules anymore
but there's still quite a taboo
about a character smoking.
So I thought, okay, if I'm going
to bring in this grandfather
who the kids won't at first, then
I'll make him the ultimate evil.
I'll make him a smoker.
So one way I'm going to show you
how I write is by exploring some
of the layers that go
into one tiny scene.
So layer one is always inspiration.
There's one scene in "The
Lotterys" which is inspired
by this crazy museum in Toronto.
It's a 19 century museum
that they've added a
wonderful crazy glass section
to called the Royal Ontario Museum.
So I took my kids there
to an exhibition
about the culture of
ancient Mesopotamia.
And so I took notes on my phone.
Maybe I've got particularly fat
thumbs but the notes all would come
out looking really messy and
then my phone auto corrects
them incorrectly.
So this is what I would've
written on my phone.
Finn [inaudible].
And then the phone corrected it
to fun fringe doing
cat's cradle asthma time.
And then months later, I would've
looked at that and tried to figure
out what I meant and I knew there
was no asthma involved in the scene.
So what I think I meant was Finn,
my son driving me mad doing
cat's cradle all the time,
because he recently came back from
summer camp with a wool and string
and was obsessed with making shapes.
So I decided it would be
a good start for a scene
if the Lotterys were all at
this museum and if Aspen,
the most troublesome one, was
doing a lot cat's cradling.
Then in this museum, I saw this
amazing ancient statue and I wrote
down Kong status, what
if lassoed this.
And my phone corrected this to
kings state what I had [inaudible].
I think what I meant was the king
statue, what if he lassoed it,
what if my naughty
son was even naughtier
and if he used his
cat's cradle string
to lasso this ancient
and priceless statue.
So, you know, like I say, my
kids are extremely useful to me.
Any time they behave
badly in public,
I think what if that
went even farther.
So here's my rough
draft of that scene.
So this is Sumac who's a
really good girl trying
to find her troublesome
sister Aspen.
And the bits I put
in brackets are bits
which at the time I'm
not sure about.
First drafts can be so messy.
You can see, you don't
even need to be able
to spell the word "lassoing."
She finds her big sister
two rooms back all alone
with a 3000-year-old stone statue
and making a pretty good attempt
at lassoing it with her
cat's cradle string.
Aspen, you want us
to get totally banned
from the uh-oh building for life?
Oh, I should explain.
Sorry. My son at the age of
three pointed at that museum
with all the crazy shards of
glass and he said, "uh-oh."
And I realized he thought
the museum had just exploded.
So in our family, I think
every family has family slang.
We've always called
it the uh-oh building.
Her sister only giggles,
sniggers, brackets justifies self,
that means I couldn't think at the
time how Aspen would justify it.
So then the first draft
turns into a sort
of a smooth looking prose
for the first time ever.
And then the drafts that come after
that are following the principle
of what's called "killing
your darlings"
which although I illustrated it
with the picture of Finn trying
to throttle his sister on
Halloween and it really means,
look at all the bits you're really
fond of and say to yourself,
do you actually need that
bit, is it good for the book.
And if not, cut it.
And I'm going to finish with
one of the pictures I like best
from the book where the Lotterys
are having a family meeting
which they call a fleeting and
they're having it on the trampoline
because being the kind of
family they are, they don't need
to do things in the usual
way or in the usual places.
And Caroline also did a lot of
lovely pictures for the book
which are in silhouette
and I love this
because it turns the
whole family into a kind
of multi-armed, multi-limbed
monster.
It sort of brings them
all together and
yet you can still glimpse
who the individuals are.
And I suppose one of the things
I'm asking in this book is,
is love a pie, meaning
Sumas has a feeling
that by including this new
grandfather, everybody else
in the family is going to end up
with less time, less attention
from the parents, less of everything
and so really the question
that she's asking herself in
this book is, is it possible
to include somebody else and love
somebody else and still for there
to be more than enough
love to go around.
Thank you very much.
Any questions out there?
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Definitely although The
Lotterys is a series,
I'm still writing for
adults just as much.
Yeah, I've always written
in a few different genres.
I've always liked writing historical
fiction and contemporary fiction
and I'm feeling the same
way about the new pleasures
of contemporary children's
fiction that, you know,
they can't replace
adult fiction for me.
And obviously my much darker stuff
I have to write for adults because,
you know, there's a limit to what
I'm going to put the kids through.
I'm currently working on the
second Lotterys one we just set
in midwinter instead of summer
and is set during a big ice
storm that shut down Toronto.
And so I've been enjoying
the pleasures of, you know,
writing about ice and snow
and cold in midsummer.
>> Are the Lotterys millionaires?
>> Emma Donoghue: You know,
they are presumably millionaires
in that they have enough money to
all give up their jobs and stay
at home and that must
be a lot of money,
but I don't have any idea
how much money they won
because I've never asked them.
They're just not the kind of
people who talk about money much.
And any time the kids ask their
parents how much money there are,
the parents are like
enough, don't worry about it.
Did you have a followup?
>> I was going to ask them why
don't they live in a mansion.
>> Emma Donoghue: Why don't
they talk about the money?
>> Why don't they live in a mansion?
>> Emma Donoghue: Oh, well, you
know, it is pretty mansionly.
You're only seeing the front of
it but it's got over 30 rooms.
But that means a lot
of housework too.
So the Lotterys have to do
chores and they have a big half.
They borrowed this idea from
Hogwarts in the Harry Potter books.
They have a big top half
with little slips of paper
that mention the chores
and their parents say,
"Come and do your lots."
So they pick out lots,
like drawing lots,
and each lot would say
things like, you know,
clean the cat litter trays or,
you know, roll all the bags
of laundry downstairs
to the basement.
I've always liked books
which are about, you know,
funny kinds of communities like say
The Wombles books, where, you know,
the characters in those
books just take for granted
that that's how their world works.
So not quite pure fantasy but books
where, you know, a family is normal
to itself, but outsiders
would find it strange.
>> I have a question for you.
>> Emma Donoghue: Sorry?
Which one is more difficult?
Oh, it's way for difficult
to write for kids.
Yeah. But that's not going to
stop me but it takes a lot of time
and work because you have to
put in all the same ingredients
that you would for adults.
You know, you can't, like, do
a quickie version of anything.
There has to be just as
much profundity and just
as much real thought in the books,
but then you have to make sure
that there's something
happening on every page as well
and that the words
are not too difficult.
And often you can't assume that
your child readers will have heard
of things but nor do you want
to cut out every single thing
that a child wouldn't have heard of.
So there's a lot of, you know,
dithering about every little bit
of it, but it's so worth
it too, because, you know,
good kids' books are just best ever.
So I'm finding a lot of adults
read kids' books as well.
You know, there's quite a cross over
audience there and I'm always trying
to get my adult friends to
read really good kids or --
books, say the Philip
Pullman trilogy.
I often offer that to adult readers
who don't think they would ever
like kids' books because, you know,
these distinctions are not meant
to keep us in our little
reading boxes, you know.
>> I have a question
for you over here.
I wrote, not wrote, you wrote it,
you wrote "Frog Music" and "Room"
and those were completely
different voices,
completely different stories,
completely different everything
and I haven't read the
children's book but it sounds
like there's a lot
of voices in that.
How do you keep all the voices --
Well first off, how do you decide
what you want the voices to be
and then how do you
keep them straight?
>> Emma Donoghue: It would
be much harder to write books
in which the voices
were all similar.
I tend to write a few things at once
or at least I'll do like a few weeks
on something and then a few
weeks on something else.
And the more different those
projects are the better.
So if I'm working on say a
film script of "Frog Music,"
which is what I'm doing at the
moment, and then if I'm working
on the second Lotterys book,
there's no one sentence
which could be in both
those projects.
So that helps me keep it
distinct, but also I work hard
on making the voices really
flavorful to begin with.
So a character like, let me think,
the father who's called PopCorn
in this book, he's
particularly silly, you know.
So he always calls his children
things like prodigious progeny.
You know, he uses very theatrical
funny language and he's always kind
of flippant and a bit English.
So once I've mulled over what
he's like, and done a list
of his favorite phrases
and his favorite nicknames
and what he would tend
to call his children,
then every time I'm writing
him, I'm sort of dipping
in that particular
paint bottle, you know,
and with my historical fiction,
I suppose I do a huge
amount of research.
So I'm really soaked in that era
and I have the kind of the slang
of the time and the, you know,
the root words of the time
and the sentence structures of
the time as well because it's not
so much that you always have to
use very 19th century words say
when you're writing 19th century
fiction but having a few terms
or phrase that sound
found Victorian,
they really help the reader
trust the whole thing after that.
So really the more different voices
can be, the easier it is for me
to handle them all, you know.
I suppose it's like
a circus, you know.
You don't want two strong men.
You want them all to play
very different vivid roles.
Thank you all so much.
I really enjoyed this.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.